Well.
Welcome to the Jomo show,
the show where we give you tips and tricks on how to land a successful career in
tech. Now, today we have a special guests. Well, Yuko, how are you doing?
So I guess first thing's first happy Halloween. Happy Halloween.
Do you have any, uh, costume?
Ah, I'm still working on mine right now. Um,
but I am going to show on Tuesday on Halloween night. Uh,
so I'm pretty excited for that.
Awesome. Yeah. Yeah. I'm thinking of just bringing this to the office,
showing everyone and stuff like that, but yeah. Cool. I guess, uh,
I'll start with some short questions. Cool. Just to see, you know,
if we can be friends, so there's no right answer. Okay.
But there's a right answer if you want to be my friend. Okay.
Hopefully I answered them. Right. Mac or PC Mac though, though. Okay. All right.
Good answer. iPhone or Android?
IPhone. Okay.
Favorite programming language.
Swift.
Okay. That's okay. Cause you're an iOS developer and uh, okay.
I guess what about favorite editor.
For your editor? You know, I have a love and hate relationship with this one,
but it has to be.
X code. That makes sense. Yeah.
Can you code it like not on X code iOS.
It must be a lot harder. It is. Cause I'm all about the VIM. Yeah. Race.
You can code.
On them, but then you don't get all.
The LinkedIn. Yeah, that's true. I think that's why I'm not a iOS engineer.
I can never do that. Okay. What about this coffee or tea?
Hm, I'm going say T T yeah.
Nice. That's good. I actually don't drink either. That wasn't even a question.
I like Hintwater. Do you know what this, do you guys have this? No,
we don't have that sponsored by Hintwater.
Every other tech company and that we have a ton of LaCroix. What is that?
The court it's like the it's like flavored sparkling water is in the little
cans.
Yeah. Yeah. Those are right. They're kind of like hint, but you know, fizzle,
I guess. Yeah. Cool. Cool. Cool.
So you are an iOS engineer at Patrion. Okay, cool. Cool.
Yeah. Um, so yeah, I'm a, I was an engineer at Patrion.
I've been doing iOS development for about three ish years now. Um,
and I haven't done any other like types of mobile programming, but yeah.
I used to work at Intuit and I worked on the TurboTax and QuickBooks apps and
now I work at Patrion. I've been there for about a year and a half now. Um,
but yeah, it's really fun. I like it a lot. Cool.
Wait, so in Intuit, where you an iOS engineer also. Okay.
What about the four done before then? I was in school.
And did you do any iOS programming things?
I took one class called mobile programming where we made an iOS app,
but actually even before that there was a software engineering course that I
took where we made an Android app.
So I made an Android app before I made an iOS app. Uh,
so I use like Andrew's studio and then I came to X code and I was like,
Escalade is so much cleaner. Don't hate me. Apple's.
Great. Yeah. Um, I guess one thing I always wanted to know,
like how will you even get started with Iowa scent like development?
Because I always wanted to make apps. Cause that's what that's, what's cool now.
Like nobody uses like web anymore, but like, it's just so hard.
Like the first thing I pop up is like X code and then it tells me to download
all these things. I don't know what they are. And then I dunno frames.
Is that something like, I have no idea how do I even get started?
Yeah. Yeah. So I was definitely,
there's a lot of different things that you need to learn in order to get
started. And so that can be really intimidating for folks. Um,
when I first started doing iOS development in that mobile mobile programming
class, uh,
we opened up X code and there were so many knobs that I was just like, ah,
panic kit, can't do it. Um, and so when I asked her to thankfully,
there's a TA that walked us through how to use it.
And so once we understood how to use X code, it obviously became a lot easier.
Um, but in terms of the actual, like programming language Swift and objective C,
which people don't typically learn in school, uh,
as well as like all the different, you know,
patterns and frameworks and stuff that you have to use,
it can be really intimidating. Um,
but thankfully there's a lot of online resources,
like a lot of other programming languages.
And the two that I recommend for getting started is one actually by Apple.
Um, Apple is really trying to get more people to do iOS development. Okay.
That was part of the motivation for inventing the programming language Swift.
Uh, and so if you actually look up like iOS tutorial by Apple, um,
there is a great tutorial that teaches you how to make your first app. Uh,
and it shows you kind of step by step,
like where to click and all those kinds of things, as well as what to code. Um,
my second most recommended, uh, like two actually I have three.
So when my second one is a website called Ray wonder like.com, um,
Ray wonder like is the person that owns this website.
And he has a bunch of writers that writes these tutorials and the iOS tutorials
are super, super good. Um, they, again are step-by-step tutorials and like,
here's what you need to code. Here's what you need to do. Uh,
and it has everything from like how to even get started to like,
here's how to use this very specific framework to do a very specific thing.
Like I don't maybe want to like use the camera to detect if it's a
fruit or if it's a hot dog, in some cases. Yes.
In Silicon Valley, I watch a little bit of it.
Yeah. It was like Jin yang who was like a developer.
He made an app that can detect what the food is.
And then he sh he does the demo. He's like, Oh, it's hot dog.
But then when you put it something else, it just says not hot dog.
And that's all I can do.
Um, don't go to DC this year. Apple came out with like, uh, AR VR kit,
I air kit and like AR kit, like the, they basically integrated into iPhone.
Right. And so they were doing a bunch of demos there.
So many references to like hot dog, not hot dog. I feel like Silicon Valley,
the show one. Yeah.
But yeah, that's cool. So I guess like, you know, backend engineers,
we have like some inside jokes, you know,
we talk about certain things like certain bugs that we encounter frequently.
Yeah. Are there any iOS things?
Yeah, my favorite, yeah. My favorite ones are against X code,
which is the IDE that we used to do development, but X code is like, like,
I think any IDE can be really finicky. And so there's two jokes,
running jokes that I like love. And one is, um, like if, uh,
we say to each other like, Oh,
have you tried cleaning derive data and drive data?
It's just like this cache that the,
the X code uses to be able to compile faster. But if something doesn't work,
then that's like, kind of generally the first thing that you do.
I think one of my top tweets is actually a meme I made out and that's my claim
to fame on Twitter. Um, and there's actually my,
my second favorite one against excavators. There's just like tumbler. Uh,
I forgot what it's called it. It must be something called like, X coats, others,
but it's like a text message thread between yourself and X code.
And so it likes throws different errors and stuff, and you're just like, wait,
but why does it? And they're just like, it just repeats the air.
It's just all these things that ex-co desert are just so annoying,
but I love that block so much interesting.
Because like your favorite editor is X code, but it's also like super annoying.
Yeah. Yeah. That's, that's interesting. Yeah. Cool.
I guess I want to know more like about you. Cool. You know, like, for example,
I guess just tell me about your life story and then we'll go to high school and
then college, all this stupid dirt. I want to know.
All right. We're going to be real vulnerable and real honest here. Yeah. Um,
cool. So I was born in the East coast in Massachusetts, specifically.
Yeah. And, uh, I was really little when we moved back to Japan,
my family and I, um, and we lived there for about two years. Part of Japan, uh,
in Kobe. Yeah. Yeah. It's kind of near like Koto Osaka area,
but Kobe is known like most commonly tied to Kobe beef. Oh yeah. Kobe Bryant,
you know? Yeah. Um,
so we lived there for like two years and then we moved back to the States when I
was like three something. So I barely remember living in Japan. Right. Um,
but I lived on the East coast until I was about 10 living between New York and
Connecticut. And so like my early childhood memories were like, you know,
having snow days and like playing the leaves and all that kind of stuff. Um,
I was also like the only Asian kid in school for a lot of the times. So yeah.
Uh, and then when I moved, uh, I moved to San Diego, California when I was 10.
Yeah. San Diego just really, you know, dude.
Um, and yeah, I went to middle school, high school there,
and then I went to college at UC San Diego,
which was only like 20 minutes away from my house,
but I went there and got my degree in computer science and then English. Cool.
Well, yeah, I guess like one question. Cause, um,
when I was a kid like an elementary school, I guess, you know,
I like things that are more engineering type, but I just didn't know.
For example,
I liked building Legos or like playing this game called kingdom hearts,
one small part of the game where you could build a spaceship. And I loved that.
I played it more than the actual game itself, you know,
I just love building things. So what about you, like when you were a child,
like, did you do anything like that? Not really.
Really. Actually. I'm trying to think back and I couldn't really like dig up,
like I wasn't someone who played with a bunch of Legos. Yeah. Um, I also wasn't,
I guess like one thing that I think was common to a lot of like girls might,
or like that were my age was playing Neo pets. Yeah.
Yeah. I used to play like the stock market and the old pads.
I used to trade like the marketplace, like buy and sell stuff.
And I trained my little Kiko. I think that was the no pet name.
The Kiko can look really strong. And I was like beating everyone in the stadium.
Yeah.
Yeah. My, I always like made,
made sure like that my like new pets page or whatever it used to like make my
page look good, which gets to that.
I think that was kind of one of my first exposures to coding. Um,
but also I was always like getting free omelets score the wheel of fortune,
getting all the free stuff. And that was super fun.
But other than that, I think generally,
like I really liked math when I was growing up.
Minus one that's free.
Uh, and so like playing computer games. Yeah. I was that person, um,
playing computer games that were like math oriented,
even if it was like an educational one.
So, you know.
School, they try to get you to play these educational games.
Yeah.
None of them was games.
And there was one game that I loved playing that was like this like cash
register game.
You're supposed to like.
Form the amount with your exact, like which coins and changes and stuff.
And I was like, this is so cool.
This is what I want to be dynamic programming algorithm for that
maybe I did, but I was just like,
this is what I would want to do when I grow up.
I want to like do this Mackey stuff and whatever. Like I love that game.
Not even a game. It was fun. I love that. Um, but yeah, I, I think, yeah,
and then like, as I became a teenager,
Zynga was a big thing and also like customizing your zing a page. Yeah. Uh,
and like, even though a lot of it was kind of like, you know,
I didn't make a whole template for Zynga for my page,
but being able to tweak little things here and there to make it look like how I
wanted it to, I guess it was kind of an early indicator.
I think. Yeah. That's true. Like tweak that you have to like code a little bit,
like at least like the hex numbers for yeah.
A little bit like going into CSS and making sure that like I have the right
color, um, like colors were kind of like the big thing,
just a lot of like UI type things and like moving,
like maybe I don't want this here, but I want it here.
And reading through the HTML slash XML or whatever it was written in to do that.
Yeah. Yeah. So, I mean,
since you liked math so much where you're like a nerd in school, I kind of was,
I was definitely.
He doesn't second and third grade, you do those like multiplication tables,
like cheats that you have to finish in five minutes.
I was like always the first one to be done because it competitive. Yeah.
But also like, my dad taught me my most applications tables, like earlier on.
So I was like, Oh my parents.
It's like a Cantonese, not a song, but they make memorize in Japanese.
So I'm actually pretty bad at multiplication when we do like contests like me
against like a friend, because they would say it in French,
I have to translate in Cantonese and then do the multiplication and then
retranslate it it's for French. Oh my God. Yeah. It was so hard.
So then people thought it was super slow. Yeah. It was just a language barrier.
It was a language barrier. Yeah. Yeah. So what about, what about high school?
Like who who'd you hang out with?
Were they like math whiz kids or like kids? Yeah. Um.
Well, so my school was really big. My high school had about,
I think my graduating class was about 700 people,
so there thousands of kids in school. So when there's that many kids in school,
there's a lot of like clicks. Right.
So we had like the skater kids and the jocks and the cheerleaders.
Oh, the skater. Oh yeah. But we were more like rappers and skaters.
Oh, that was the thing for you guys.
I don't think there were any rappers at my school.
We didn't rap. They just liked rap. I would take skills.
That would be really impressive. Quite impressive. But yeah.
Yeah. Um, so like, I, I was like, I'm not like a nerd nerd.
I'm not going to be in like science Olympiad or anything like that,
but I did play tennis and I did orchestra and I was
also like, yeah, yeah, absolutely. I played violin. Oh no.
That's nice. Very difficult.
It is. Yeah. Yeah. It's, it's really, it had a lot of fun though.
And my orchestra class was always like very tight knit and really small.
We went to, um, like Disneyland everywhere for festival.
And we went to New York one year together, um, to play at Carnegie hall,
which was like really, really cool. Yeah.
That was probably my favorite year of Oregon show.
We were just like super tight knit and we had a lot of fun.
Our teacher was like really cool too. Um,
and so I think I hung out with like the orchestra kids a lot of the time. Um,
but it was basically like orchestra kids and like speech and debate kids were
kind of together, but really,
it was just like a lot of Asian people at my school. Um,
or like I was hanging out with the Asian people at my school. And so yeah,
we tended to all be in like the AP classes, like through like the nerves.
Yeah. You guys were nerds. I mean, just, just like listen to yourself.
[inaudible] speech and debate. Yeah.
I, it was weird because it was kind of like in my own little bubble,
because it was such a big school that I didn't,
I didn't ever feel like I was like a nerd.
Cause like I would never mix with like the kids who didn't take AP AP classes.
Yeah.
Those people would call you nerd.
But I didn't care about it. So I had to keep my self esteem somewhere, you know?
Yeah. But yeah, I w I think I was like kind of shy kind of quiet, but also like,
you know, um, yeah, I guess I was kind of like a nerdish.
Yeah. But I guess you didn't do any programming before college.
I did not know. I was like,
I thought computer science was for like geeks and like old white men.
Um, yeah. Yeah. Cause.
I just like my thought of, yeah.
I didn't really think that computer science was for me,
like the way that computer science and software engineers are depicted in the
media is often, you know, like gamers and like yeah. Yeah.
And none of them looked like me. And I was also just like, I, I,
I think that's a little too intense for me. I'm not that into computer.
It's true. But if you're not getting better, like in media, especially,
definitely all like we have coders, like, you know,
it was very diverse back when we got like, brogrammers now not nerdy at all.
You know, you work out.
Although my secret about board grabbers,
I think it's just like the nerdy people trying to overcompensate a little bit.
We're not a nurse, not a program at all, but, uh, yeah.
I mean, I try to be, I try to work out and stuff like that, but yeah,
I do think there's a little bit of overcompensation. Yeah.
Working out and being healthy is a good thing. Exactly. Drinking soil.
And every day.
We'll have to take care of yourself. So that's fine. That's totally cool.
How the hell did you end up in computer science then if you didn't even want to
be.
Was I, I thought so when I entered college,
I thought I was going to be a chemistry major because I was like chemistry
school. There's like equations.
And then you do experiments to prove the equations are right. And it's like,
Whoa. But I took my first class, which was, uh,
like quantum mechanics and chemistry and lose like freshman year,
fall quarter. And I was like, what the heck? Yeah. I was like,
what does quantum mean? Or what does mechanics mean? It just,
it was really intimidating. And I was like,
I don't think I can actually do this, even if I did understand it. Right. Uh,
and then I tried neuroscience that also didn't work out.
And I was just talking to my former mates one day, um, at my dorm.
And I was like, I don't really know what I'm going to declare next. Like,
I'm kind of out of ideas. And he was a computer engineer,
which was another form of computer science at my school.
And I had just taken a intro to logic class as part of the
philosophy department. And that was kind of like,
was really just like doing proofs and stuff,
but just the logical nature of it was like made a lot of sense to me.
Um, and so I told my friend about that and he was like,
you should try computer science. Cause literally it's just like all logic.
And I was like, Oh, there's a major, that's all logic. Uh,
and so yeah,
I took an intro to computer science class and that was the first intro to
whatever class that I was like,
I kind of like this and I think I can understand a lot of it. Um,
and that's when it clicked it. I was just like, that's it,
I'm doing computer science. And then it just like,
next thing I knew it was in my second, third,
fourth year and I was a computer science major.
Yeah. So I guess now, like I'm curious, like what do you,
what do you do outside of work aside from YouTube saying now, you know?
Cause yeah.
Yeah. Well,
I would say I was going to say YouTube because it takes quite a bit of time.
I mean, I'm happy to do it, but like, you know, it's, it's a solid hobby now.
Right. Um, other than that I think, yeah. I like like to hang out with friends,
um, like I have a cat and a dog and so hanging out with them, um, watching,
watching YouTube, uh,
I don't actually have like side projects very often for coding all like start
I've started a couple before,
but I haven't fully like committed like two months to one.
Uh, and so yeah, I'm, I'm like,
I think I'm someone who actually was actually really bad at holding hobbies.
I like play guitar for like a month and then I'll be like, I'm done, I'll play.
Like, I'll go to the gym for like a month. And I'm like, okay, I'm done.
And then I do, it's just like, I try a bunch of stuff and then I like stopped,
but I used to like beat myself up over this. Cause I was like, wait,
we can't do anything. But now I'm just like, you know what,
you're an adult and you can do whatever you want. And I'm like, yeah,
I do what I want with my time.
Exactly. Do you want to be an iOS engineer? Like forever?
Like what's your five-year plan?
That's a good question. Um,
it's something that I've been thinking about really like a lot recently. Um,
until like a couple months ago I was like,
I'm going to be an iOS engineer or at least a software engineer forever. Um,
I didn't really see myself going into management or like being like the own
owner of a company or anything like that. Uh, but more recently I've,
I've been more open to the idea of like becoming a manager.
So right now my five-year plan, I think looks like,
like I still really want to up my skills as a software engineer.
I think there's still some stuff there. Um, I am like,
I feel like I have pretty good solid like coding skills now,
but in terms of like architecting a whole system or owning the delivery of a big
thing, like those are kind of skills that I want to have more of. Um,
so that's what I'm kind of trying to do over the next year. Uh,
and then like probably maybe considering going into some sort of management
position maybe. Um, but at the same time,
like if I feel that what I'm doing in terms of like owning big systems and big
decisions at work is really fulfilling, then I might just keep doing that.
But really I think like it's fun to be evaluating at all times,
like what I want to do with my life. Um,
and like YouTube has like really changed a lot of that for me. Cause I'm like,
I like to have a big impact on other people, um,
with like what I have in my brain and what experiences that I've had.
And so like maybe YouTube is something I like really lean into as well. Uh,
so yeah, I guess we'll see.
But I think definitely going to stay in tech at least,
but really trying to think of ways to like broaden my impact and to help, um,
some of those things that are trying to happen in the world right now. Um,
specifically like things like getting more women into tech, um, you know,
also helping my company with their mission, um,
to get more creators paid and help them get a good living salary for the art
that they make. So, yeah, we'll see.
Nice, nice. Super exciting. And yeah.
Do you want to say anything to my 20 viewers?
Sure. Um, definitely like Jonah's like future, uh,
series is going to be super funny. I saw a teaser of it and it's so funny.
So I'm really excited for that. Um, but also for some self Probo,
check out my YouTube channel. Hello my [inaudible]. Um,
and I'm on social media ever, also as hello Mico. So come check me out.
Cool. Yeah. Thanks for watching and see you next time.
Don't forget to like and subscribe.